tanner houck is pitching for the boston
red sox and even though he's had a uh a
solid season obviously the third way
through the the lineup has been trouble
for him jose ramirez who is
an elite slugger 32 home runs 86 driven
in 2-2 strike three called on the
outside corner ramirez hates it a
beautiful slider
painted by hauck and on 10 pitches he
sends down the indians in the first and
it's eli morgan pitching on the
pitcher's mount two and six for the five
nine eight era had a no decision against
the red sox last weekend ever set the
plate now the pitch
swing gonna miss got him so a strikeout
of devers who came in batting 275
fifth in the league in homers with 32
second in the league in rbis with 97.
here's another guy having a big year
right-handed hitting left fielder today
jd martinez a check of second
the pitch
swing enemies went in with a fastball
and got him
so jd martinez
strikes out two down first inning no
score for hunter renfro he's the
right-handed hitting right fielder
the rookie on deck dalbeck has 18 bombs
the pitch swung on popped him up
shallow right center ximena's fighting
the sun the indian second baseman makes
the catch and eli morgan works out of it
red sox strand a pair and the indians in
boston no score after one bobby bradley
to lead it off one two swing and a miss
he struck him out a splitter
and bradley is gone jenner out has not
thrown fastballs so far but it has not
mattered one away so what two down here
is you chang who hammered against the
red sox in the series in cleveland the
pitch the runner goes swinging in a miss
he struck him out with a sinking
fastball and the inning is over
three punch outs already through two for
help no score after one and a half base
is empty two down no score in the second
for second baseman jack lopez
the next delivery is swung on and missed
and eli morgan has struck out three and
the drive and red sox are scoreless
going to the third brings up
daniel johnson one two pitch johnson
swings and misses it a splitter down and
away oh he's had a really good one today
that's the pitch they wanted him to
work on when he was sent to worcester
early this year four strikeouts here's
rosario grounded into a double play his
first time up
here it is and a swing at a miss mission
an inside fastball and donnie goes
that's five punch-outs for tender houck
after two and a half two down for rafael
devers the pitch
swinging a miss struck him out what an
inning for morgan here's alex verdugo
walked his first time up left-handed
hitting outfielder here comes the pitch
swaying and a miss good fastball
as he got verdugo to chase one upstairs
that strength three now bobby dalbeck
will step in here's the 2-2 swing gonna
miss strike three he got it with another
slider dull back down on strikes side
retired we'll head to the fifth one down
here comes yoo jang he struck out his
first time up three and two to the
right-handed hitting chang the pitch in
there strike three he throws him with a
slider
and tanner's got his sixth strikeout
after the lead off double from lavornway
in the third inning
houck is now retired eight straight
and here comes the aforementioned lavon
wing the one-two pitch swing and a miss
he struck him out did
tanner hulk he's pitching like a man in
rarefied air today we go to the bottom
of the fifth and raphael devers will be
the batter
devers has been up twice and struck out
twice
wide open stance from that left side
here's the pitch
swung on ground ball first base dug out
by bradley takes it to the bag in time
and morgan works out of the jam
no damage done we will head to the sixth
no score at fenway park the tribe in the
red sox
the red sox 15
runners inherited and five have scored
for robles
you can strand three here if he can
retire harold ramirez who's single to
center and light a bullet deep to right
renfro was playing shallow went back to
the track to make the catch
very hard hit ball robles ahead all in
one
here's the pitch
swinging the ground ball hits off the
pitcher rose to the first baseman what a
lucky break out at first robles got
nailed with it and he's limping hit him
off the uh left or
shin and carry him right to bobby dull
back away the outer first that ball was
hit probably 100 miles an hour and
ticketed for center field kick save and
a beauty
all the way wow red sox really get lucky
jd martinez the three-hole hitter in the
left fielder
the pitch swing of the miss strike him
out
so morgan has struck out seven
bobby dahlbeck
is the batter struck out his last time
up against morgan
now the one-two delivery
swinging nms winkran wipes him out
so this game is still goose eggs across
the board the indians nothing the red
sox nothing bradley zimmer flied the
left and then tried to bunt and popped
it to the first baseman
bradley zimmer has it picked by bobby
dalbeck for the first down to seven
a wicked one hopper that short hopped
him right near the foul line about 10
feet beyond the bag and he scooped it
and did it himself for the out
crappy devers is struck out twice and
grounded the first
3-2 pitch
and
drills it left center field
he is incredible three-run bomb for
raffi and the red sox lead at three
nothing
and raffy is as excited as we've ever
seen him
incredible
once in a generation player right there
so the tribe gets the lead off man
aboard for bobby bradley
who has struck out grounded out and
walked
swung on hip pretty well to left down
the line it's slicing fair ball it'll
short hop the wall in the corner ramirez
is going to be waved home he is going to
score from first on a double into the
left field corner by bobby bradley
get it back by bradley shooting one down
that left field line and the indians for
the second day in a row bring the tying
run to the plate in the ninth inning
trailing three to
one in the hands of fran mill reyes
bradley at third two down in the ninth
reyes awaiting the 2-2 pitch
here it comes
swinging the drive to deep left away
back
a majestic
two-run homer to left
friend mil reyes
down to his last strike
the big man comes through we are tied at
three
a very selective hitter
most of the time he's had some huge
clutch moments looking for a walk off
here
pace is loaded with two down
here's the pitch
swinging a drive into right field back
on it is johnson he can't get it and the
red sox win
verdugo the hero and it's 4-3 boston
you